Gilles c'est incroyable parce que je me
suis vraiment demandé quelle note
j'allais te mettre c'était vraiment sur
le curseur j'ai vraiment hésité parce
que il y a comme chez toi quelque chose
qui n'est pas enfin qui est de
paranormal en fait
non mais c'est vrai c'est à dire que je
pense et d'ailleurs je crois que je t'ai
reconnu je pense que tu n'es pas humain
je pense que tu es en fait un
extraterrestre venu pour nous surveiller
je crois je crois c'est vrai que les
extraterrestres ça va sur terre ça a été
ton week-end
c'est sympa
elle a perdu le cerveau mais je pense ça
véritablement de Gilles je pense que
Gilles en fait est un mutant qui est
venu pour nous observer oui à mutant je
pense qu'il n'est pas peut-être
exactement non mais tu es l'ADN de TPMP
moi j'adore débattre avec toi je suis
rarement d'accord avec toi parce que je
pense que tu as des idées complètement
somnies
tu travailles énormément je te vois
quand même beaucoup beaucoup travaillé
pour dire autant de conneries je trouve
ça fascinant enfin pour moi c'est
vraiment une fascination je t'ai enlevé
en fait un petit point finalement pour
l'hygiène parce que c'est le fait que tu
prennes qu'une douche par semaine
on va passer à tiens Valérie alors Gilou
tu ne t'uses pas ça fait quoi maintenant
10 ans 11 ans que tu fais TPMP
il est fidèle à lui-même il gueule tout
le temps il voit des complots partout il
est dans l'excès tout le temps il
exubérant mais en même temps il bosse
les dossiers en même temps il est là
quand c'est du divertissement mais il
est là aussi quand c'est des débats de
fond bref sur tous les champs de TPMP il
est présent et pour toutes ces raisons
Gilles je voulais te mettre 10 sur 10 et
je me suis dit non c'est c'est non faut
pas faut pas parce qu'après tu essaies
de confiance donc j'étais quand même mis
un très beau 8
[Applaudissements]
Daniel chérie alors moi je t'ai mis une
très bonne note parce que je t'admire de
dire autant de conneries avec autant
d'aplombs c'est pas beau
tu es un maître pour moi et je t'ai mis
9 parce que le nombre
que c'est le nombre de gens que tu
représentes quand on fait les sondages
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
beaucoup de travail naturel
Sacha le base
mon très cher
à la base
zéro
parce que je pense que sur toute la
planète les 7 milliards d'êtres humains
vous êtes l'être humain avec lequel je
suis le moins d'accord chaque phrase est
égale une connerie avec vous Gilles dans
l'émission en démontre les sondages de
vous et vos amis de la France insoumise
mes amis ça c'est ce que vous dites
moi je me demande même si
tu es débile tellement c'est contraire à
ce que pense tout le monde en fait vous
êtes complètement à l'Ouest après je me
suis rendu compte que au final vous êtes
pas si mauvais que ça pourquoi parce que
vous êtes le seul à à dire des conneries
donc il faut quand même valoriser le
fait que vous soyez seul et aussi il
faut dire que sans vous il n'y a pas de
débat dans l'émission ou en tout cas
très peu de débats donc pour le mérite
de créer du débat dans l'émission parce
que c'est sûr que c'est pas que les
positions de Bernard Montiel qu'on va
avancer
[Rires]
mais vu que vous créez un peu de débat
dans l'émission je rajoute un vraiment
parce que je suis sympa que c'est la fin
d'année je vous mets 10 voilà
incroyable
Bernard moi je passe outre la gênance
quand tu danses et tout ça je trouve ça
épouvantable
et vraiment ça bouge pas de comprendre
ouais ça m'angoisse quand tu danses
vraiment c'est effrayant c'est effrayant
et mais en dehors de ça je crois que tu
es vraiment indispensable à l'émission
j'adore que tu es très souvent contre
nous tu réveilles le débat tu nous
pousses aussi à dire des choses et c'est
très intéressant de travailler avec toi
en plus je sais que tu es un vrai
bosseur donc je vais mettre une autre
que je pense vraiment parce que je te
retrouve remarquable et indispensable
ici voilà
[Applaudissements]
il est le meilleur
c'est beau ce qui libère
Géraldine tu me donneras un autre tout à
l'heure ok ça calmera un peu tout le
monde
il y a un engouement s'emporte
Gilou
ma lumière sur ce plateau
le seul qui arrive à me réanimer quand
ça va pas le seul qui est là pour moi à
ce point-là le seul qui arrive à cerner
dans le regard on se comprend on est en
face depuis 6 ans maintenant comme moi
Daniel et moi Gilou bah en fait je te
trouve aucun défaut parce que
humainement parlant au niveau du chaud
au niveau de ce que tu penses tu dis ce
que tu veux tu es le tonton barjot et
c'est ce que j'aime chez toi tu sais
danser tu sais crier tu sais t'énerver
tu sais tout faire et pour ça je t'aime
et je te mets 12
alors d'où ce sera pas pris en compte
merci merci
tu te remets t'inquiète pas mon chéri là
c'est vrai que ça se passe très bien
j'ai laissé ça va ça va un peu moins
bien se passer maintenant
tu veux qu'on fasse le stagiaire avant
qu'on fasse Géraldine
moi aussi je t'aime bien je t'ai mis une
bonne note très bien alors je t'ai mis
une bonne note de par ton ancienneté tu
étais déjà l'émission je faisais du
patin à roulettes au Parc Monceau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non j'ai mis 9 non non
au niveau de la mémoire à l'école
un peu
bravo en tout cas bravo allez bravo
termineras pas
chaque jour tu repousses avec panache
tes limites de la connerie tout
intervention et dénuie du bon sens et
ton dépit du bon sens quand c'est pas
pour défendre les squatteur c'est pour
nous ceux avec Fatou en plus cette année
tu as exigé que je t'invite dans un très
bon restaurant et que Fatou parce que tu
es intervenu dans un documentaire j'ai
trouvé ça très moche néanmoins tu es mon
préféré autour de cette table tu es mon
ami donc j'ai voulu te mettre un 4
bravo vraiment un bravo sans ironie
aucune de ma part
tu es vraiment le meilleur c'est à dire
que chaque soir inlassablement tu
exposes les faits tu es mieux qu'un
prompteur en fait tu bafouis jamais
c'est toujours une masterclass et tu as
été absent quelques jours là il y a
quelques semaines une fois deux jours il
fallait voir le regard
perdu Cyril qui cherchait pour pouvoir
dire à sa phrase GIPS
exposez-nous les faits
chez vous donc en fait tu es mieux que
Michel Marie Myriam Palomba Bertrand
Deckers et Bruno Pommard réunis tu es
tout ça en même temps
c'est malheureusement il y a les défauts
et les défauts sont très très nombreux
alors d'abord il y a des emportements un
petit peu à géométrie variable il y a
ton banquise mais en fait tu es le
négatif ou le positif de Daniel Moreau
c'est à dire qu'en fait vous êtes deux
extrêmes voilà pour moi ensuite à tes
fixé mon kyste qui sont insupportables
il y a ton féminisme aussi qui me donne
envie moi des bouffées de testostérone
il y a aussi ta surenchère victimaire
qui est juste insupportable aussi bon
bref pour toutes ces raisons j'ai failli
te mettre comme tes copains tes copains
t'aurais mis 9 tes copains ainsi tes
copains du coup moi j'ai plutôt fait
deux parce qu'en fait ça aurait été
méchant et trois hypocrites donc du coup
j'ai fait un beau dos
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je n'ai jamais vu une personne dire
autant de conneries sur un plateau de
télé ça c'est sûr tu resteras dans les
annales de la télévision mais le
problème c'est que ces conneries il les
pense vraiment plein de gens qui me
demandent dans la rue la question qui
revient le plus souvent c'est Gilles est
vraiment con ou
un rôle je dis non il n'est pas con mais
il pense que tout ce qu'il dit c'est
sincère et c'est ça sincérité
Gilles c'est vrai que
nous a montré cette année une fois de
plus que les squatteurs peuvent rentrer
chez vous sans problème sa solution
servait leur un jus de papaye
on peut tout faire
peut
tout se permettre Gilles c'est la France
de l'échec
c'est la France qui nous a mené on est
aujourd'hui absolument c'est Gilles
Verdez ses amis voilà à mes amis
c'est voilà c'est ça c'est vraiment il
symbolise ça pour moi la France de
l'échec la France de l'escalade
c'est un radar de recul
mais Gilles Verdez c'est quand même pour
moi je le dis et je le dis avec
c'est avec celui qui va nous rejoindre
dans un instant
et Géraldine Valérie bon quand même
Daniel Kelly
en vrai en vrai en vrai au niveau du
travail ça reste le seul indispensable
de TPMP
est capable de donner une info sur tous
les sujets tout capable de donner un
avis sur tous les sujets qui est capable
de se marier et de nous prendre une
bague et de ne jamais
comme je le dis à chaque fois je le dis
c'est fou parce que je ne peux pas le
blairer à l'antenne mais dans la vie
c'est un de ceux que j'aime le plus
vraiment et c'est un de ceux de que je
considère le plus commode mes amis comme
quoi on peut avoir des amis qui ont des
positions complètement différentes ce ne
sont pas mes amis
[Rires]
Gilles Verdez est pour moi
aujourd'hui
un monument
de la connerie
c'est le sacré con
je lui mets la note
de 9,75
[Applaudissements]
d'être le meilleur chroniqueur de la
saison merci Gilles
une très bonne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]